we know there are some deleted scenes
from it chapter two out there somewhere
as well as numerous key moments from
Stephen King's original novel that
didn't make the cut with that in mind
let's examine some intriguing scenes
that we didn't get to see it is a very
long novel even when you're approaching
it with the idea of turning the story
into two separate films Kings book has
the luxury of taking its time with the
characters sometimes even meandering a
bit to allow us to get to know them and
the world in which they exist and that
means while some things were left out of
the film's entirely others were heavily
abbreviated for the sake of moving along
the plot this is particularly true of
the way the adult members of the losers
Club are introduced as in King's novel
we meet them in their adult forms as
they each receive a phone call from Mike
Hanlon but we don't see much of what
they do in the immediate aftermath
because the film just needs to get them
to Derry quickly you need to come home
in the book King spends a whole chapter
with each member of the club shedding a
little more light on how they each cope
with the trauma of the phone call this
is particularly memorable in the case of
Ben Hanscom who chooses to handle it by
heading to a local bar asking the
bartender to fill a beer stein with
whiskey and then squeezing lemon juice
into his nostrils to shock his body into
taking more alcohol it's an
unforgettable scene but the film just
didn't have room for it in the film bill
den Burroughs wife Audra Phillips only
appears in the scene where bill gets the
phone call summoning him back to Derry
but in the novel she has an expanded
role as in the film
Audra is an actress who sometimes works
on film adaptations of Bill's stories
but in the book she's also drawn to
Derry as she becomes increasingly
fearful over what might happen to her
husband this leads to a confrontation
with Beverly's husband Tom Rogan who
abducts her and takes her down into its
lair when it reveals its true form the
dead lights Tom dies on the spot and
Audra falls into a catatonic state she
survives the final battle but remains
comatose until bill can revive her by
putting her on the back of his childhood
bike silver in writing free through the
streets to recapture some of the joy of
his youth
Oh
[Music]
bill and Audra kiss and then move on
with their lives it's a satisfying
subplot but it's one that the film
doesn't seem to have space for in it
chapter two both bill den bro and
Beverly Marsh are revealed to be married
but the respective spouses only get one
scene in the book the spouses are used
as more direct plot devices particularly
Tom Rogan Beverly's husband who repeats
the cycle of abuse she endured with her
father years earlier in the film we see
Tom get violent with Beverly when she
announces that she asked to go to Derry
she then fights him off and he's out of
the picture for the rest of the film in
King's novel though
Tom's abusive obsession carries him much
further as he plans to travel to Derry
himself so he can punish and ultimately
kill Beverly as well as bill in a
jealous rage this leads to it latching
on to Tom's violent persona much as it
did with Henry Bowers and using him to
kidnap Bill's wife and bring her into
its lair as a lure for the losers Club
that's the end of the line for Tom as he
dies after seeing its dead lights Tom's
violent subplot was probably just one
side villain too many for the film
so his expanded role wasn't included one
of the keys to it as both a novel and a
film adaptation is the sense that we can
always learn more about it but we can't
learn everything the creature is just
too ancient too strange and too
terrifying for us to ever fully
penetrate its origins King's novel digs
a little deeper into the entity's
backstory then the film's do but chapter
two still shows us certain things like
the media are carrying it crashing into
Earth we even get a tease of Pennywise
as early Serkis days according to
director Andy muschietti though we
almost got a little more in the form of
a flashback that would have taken the
film about 400 years into the past
he told consequence of sound
there's a scene that we shot that's in
the 1600s I decided not to put it in the
film because it was a little confusing
you know the problem is that people
sometimes want to know a little more but
if you give them too much then they're
disappointed it's like a magic trick in
a way in both the book and the film Mike
Hamlin is the driving force that brings
the adult losers club back to Derry he's
the one who stays behind the one who
does the research and in the film the
one who discovers all the finer details
of the ritual of chud and how to carry
it out because of this while the other
losers get to spend a lot of solo time
out in Derry we see more of Mike when
he's teamed up with other characters and
therefore his flashbacks to the Past
aren't quite as substantive that wasn't
always the case though according to
cinematographer check-over sa a deleted
scene from chapter 2 features Mike
returning to the site of the house fire
that killed his parents he said yeah we
shot a flashback and it's super
beautiful there is a little hint in the
movie right now when there's a little
baby Mike looking at some wall on fire
but that's a very brief moment
Varis a added that little bit would have
turned quote into a complex scene but
sadly it just didn't make the cut
in it chapter 2 the members of the
losers club head out to explore Derry as
adults in the hopes of finding a token
of their memories to use in the ritual
chut in these pieces these artifacts
that's why we're here
they are what's your sacrifice in the
book the ritual is a bit less concrete
than that and they're exploring the town
again simply to reconnect with their own
memories to understand why they came
back this rediscovery takes similar form
in both the book and the film but
certain scenes are either heavily
altered or left out entirely one of the
most memorable moments from the novel
that didn't make it to the film features
Ben Hanscom exploring not dairy high
school but the library where he spent so
much time as a child while there he
meets Pennywise costumed as Dracula with
a mouth full of razor blades that cuts
chunks of its own flesh as the creature
talks that's a horrifying image and it
also leads Ben to learn exactly what
happened to their absent friend Stanley
URIs who cuts his wrists after getting
the phone call from Mike in both the
book and the film Pennywise is scheming
against the losers Club includes
drafting the bully Henry Bowers back
into its service and helping Henry
escape the asylum where he's been
confined for nearly 30 years
Henry returns to Derry and launches his
own violent assault on the losers Club
and in the film he manages to stab Eddie
Kaz Brack through the cheek and then
attack Mike Hanlon in the library in the
novel Henry's attack is a little more
successful as he's able to injure Mike
enough to put him in the hospital and
keep him out of the ritual of chud this
gets even more complicated in the
novel's climax as Mike is attacked in
his hospital bed by a nurse possessed by
it and the other losers must use their
combined wills to send him strength to
fend off his attacker while it's nice to
have the club all together for the
ritual in the film it's a shame that we
don't get to see Mike solo struggle
during the climate in the novel a
version of the ritual of chud happens
twice in both times
it's a metaphorical battle led by Bill
den bro when Bill does the ritual as a
child he has a vision of a turtle who
gives him a little advice during a
spiritual journey the turtle is named
michurin and he's an important part of
the King cosmology that was
unfortunately left out of it chapter one
save for an Easter egg or two as it
turns out though there was almost a
scene
chapter 2 that featured the legendary
turtle Andi muschietti explained to
consequence of sound when you see James
McAvoy confronting his fear in the
flooded basement and he kills the notion
of guilt by killing himself as a kid he
jumps back in the water
he's lost there's no way out and
suddenly the eyes of Pennywise come out
of the dark but it's not penny wise it's
the turtle that is swimming by him very
soon after the kids are swimming after
it so McAvoy follows them toward the
light and he emerges back in the cavern
in other words it would have been a
pretty weird scene but hey this is a
movie about a demon clown so strange
stuff comes with the territory the final
confrontation between the losers Club
and it in Chapter two is a complicated
multi-layered affair and it features the
creature morphing into a twisted version
of the spider form that Stephen King
describes in the novel but there's one
aspect of that battle that was left out
of the film entirely either for the sake
of brevity simplicity or both in the
novel the battle with it is prolonged
and difficult and as the losers manage
to drive it back deeper into its lair
they make a horrifying discovery
a trail of black eggs the size of
ostrich eggs yeah it is giving birth to
demonic offspring so the losers
immediately decide the eggs must be
destroyed and that task Falls to Ben
Hanscom who crushes the eggs and then
chases after the rat sized spider
creatures that crawl out of each one
it's a horrifying scene in the novel
that adds an extra layer of wild
violence to the final battle but it does
seem to function as more of a side quest
than anything else in it chapter 2 the
losers are able to defeat it by making
it assume the shape of something small
and weak then crushing its heart
with this process complete they must
then race out of its lair as it
collapses around them and after escaping
they discover the house on niebolt
Street has been destroyed along with it
Stephen King's novel takes a similar
approach in that it also alters the
physical landscape of Derry in tandem
with its destruction
but in the book things are way more
apocalyptic because its presence and
malevolence is woven so deeply into the
fabric of the town its death is matched
by an enormous storm that blows through
Derry while the losers Club engaged the
enemy in battle by the time the fight is
over and it is defeated the losers
discover that much of dairy's downtown
has collapsed and my fear rises that
this means the town will die along with
it it's the same concept as the film but
here things are on a much bigger scale
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite movies are coming soon
subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
you